[Music]
maybe just give people a little bit of
connective tissue
related to your professional life
because
people see the red carpet events they
see the tv shows and they they might
assume that it's just like all
highlights all day long and i i was just
wondering if you could maybe add a
little bit of color
to
what a day in the life
actually looks like because there's so
much behind the scenes
it's seasonal for me you know one thing
i learned um
is especially now it's not as
you know entertainment has changed
significantly just in the last five
years especially after the pandemic
of the last two years
and you know streaming has kind of taken
over
you know i had a much more structured
life before you know you do a sitcom and
you you kind of you know you wake up at
four in the morning get the workout in
go to the the set do your whole thing i
usually i i mean my workout is two hours
so no matter what my call time is i'm up
at least three hours before my call time
so that i can get all my you know my
workout in my showering all that stuff
and then i go right into a usual day but
and that's a 12 hour kind of sitcom day
you know when i was doing brooklyn 99
for eight straight years
that was my my go-to and
you know
that's kind of how a day went but
now it's streaming
and the way everything is going people
have now started to do
limited series and
i'm not on brooklyn anymore but i am
doing you know
i did
a stint on
a tv series for amc called tales of the
walking dead which is going to be really
cool
but it was all in atlanta and and we
shot 15 hours and it was like shooting a
movie in 10 days you know what i mean
and that's kind of how everything goes
it's always like hurry up shoot it all
and then
now you're down for two weeks three
weeks finding out what your next thing
is
but this is the thing i never lose my
own structure you know what i mean i you
know wherever i'm at i have my the first
thing i find is where i'm going to work
out
what and then also what i'm going to eat
and also my timing of my eating i still
do intermittent fasting i'm going
on i'm in the beginning of 12 years now
straight of intermittent fasting and
doing my eight-hour window
from two to ten and then it changes by
when i go to
you know whatever time zone i'm in
and now it's funny because a lot of
times i find i can go one meal a day i
actually enjoy
skipping that two o'clock
and then maybe by three or four having a
charcuterie or something like that with
some
you know real satiating cheese and some
you know meat
and that's it and then i have a dinner
and then i'm done that's kind of the way
i've been doing it lately but the
industry changing so much and so much is
also on social media
you know it's now
they expect
every production expects to take all
your followers with them
you know so you're like doing two jobs
at the same time and this is where
i had to really really
kind of push back a little bit because
too much phone time is just not good for
you
yeah like i never bring my phone when
i'm working i leave my phone in the
trailer
i find that if you have you know if i
lose my focus i could lose my career
and the lack of focus that comes from
always checking a email always checking
a post and looking at what
people are commenting on and this kind
of stuff man it it slowly but surely
changes you and i
i saw it happening and my performances
you know and i only did it for a small
time because i immediately started to
see a decline
in my performances
it didn't look like i was there i didn't
feel present
i was somewhere else while i was saying
the lines and i said man
this is gonna hurt me
so i learned to just kind of leave all
and create a seasonal kind of thing with
my social media just kind of like
and what was crazy and what i've i
figured out i didn't lose any followers
in fact i would gain something you know
people are like where you been you know
i'm going oh my god because you get this
feeling or you got to feed the beast you
know what i mean like if you don't
if you don't keep the pipeline running
all of a sudden you're just going to run
dry but
i i found it wasn't true um i found that
when it was when i'm doing america's got
talent and it's time to promote and time
to get your social media back up and
running it's like people never left yeah
and i was like man that was a really
good thing to find out you know what i'm
saying good to test early and learn that
you can do it yeah and again i try to go
to bed as early as i can like if i can
get to bed literally at 8 30
i'm gone
because i just enjoy my mornings like
with my workout it's my piece man i put
my headphones on i'll listen to your
podcasts i listen to
some rea i read a lot of good books via
audiobook
while i'm working out that just give me
the insights and the
and the thing that i need and i i
literally i probably read a book a week
at least
and sometimes two if it gets really
rolling if the book is the books are
short
but i find that it the reading just
really keeps me
keeps me level level-headed in a world
of quick blurbs and
and people who want to excite everyone
else and get everybody riled up
one thing i like to say is the media
likes to get everyone angry and keep
them there
because it's very profitable you know
but reading
calms all that down you know what i'm
saying it's kind of like a very
it's a very realistic way of looking at
life you know i mean it's like as a as
opposed to blowing through the day it's
like you're enjoying a sunset when you
read a book you know what i'm saying
that's the analogy that i
i have for that
and it gives me great perspective
sometimes i read books on people that i
wouldn't normally
you know listen to or understand or try
to understand and then you get a deep
you get a new empathy for different
people you may not you may not even
agree
but i can definitely empathize with
points of view and where people are
coming from
and it gives nuance where there is i
mean the death of nuance has been
kind of what's happening lately
you know i mean
you